thousands of devotees have gathered in
pehelgam this base camp is the starting
point for their long journey ahead after
a thorough inspection they will walk
several kilometers to a hindu shrine in
the himalayas
they have made excellent arrangements
for us we've seen a lot of security
officers on the way they're doing a
great job in guiding us
the annual hindu pilgrimage known as the
amarnath yatra has resumed after two
years and is expected to be the largest
in history at least 250 000 people have
registered the treacherous journey takes
at least a week and involves trekking at
an altitude of nearly four thousand
meters it supports many jobs
we've faced heavy losses for two years
this is our livelihood i hope lots of
devotees turn up this year so we can
make a good living
kashmir is claimed in full by india and
pakistan but governed by both in parts
indian administered kashmir has seen
many violent uprisings against new
delhi's rule in 2019 the government
revoked the region's special status and
imposed a strict lockdown further
fueling dissent authorities say they
have received many security threats
look we have a neighbor like pakistan
which wants to disrupt the communal
harmony in the region there have been
attacks on minorities and kashmiri
hindus recently their goal is to create
sectarian tension terror groups have
always targeted the pilgrimage which is
why we made these arrangements
some experts say these elaborate
arrangements are part of a larger
political goal to assert a hindu
identity in the country's only
muslim-majority region
well there is an increasingly trust on
making it into a big
announcement and be given
so that uh has
made is a relationship as i said
cultural uniformity cultural onslaught
what happens
and
focus on unity or hindutva
understanding of places
the governing bjp has denied this and
says officials killed at least 30
fighters in the region last month
the pilgrimage ends on august 11th
authorities are expecting nearly 1
million people to attend and say they're
responsible for each person's safety
bhavni mithal al-jazeera new delhi